>> Bret: TECHNICALLY.
>> Tucker: BRET, MARTHA,
THANK YOU.
>> Martha: THANK YOU.
SEE YOU LATER.
>> Tucker: THE CAUCUSES ARE
BEING HELD FOR BOTH PARTIES
TONIGHT.
THE WORD IS DONALD TRUMP WON ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY QUESTION.
EVEN THE PRESIDENT’S CAMPAIGN IS
FOCUSED MORE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
RESULTS TONIGHT.
LARA TRUMP IS THE
DAUGHTER-IN-LAW OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND IS
ADVISING HIS CAMPAIGN.
SHE JOINS US FROM IOWA.
LARA, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> YOU’VE GOT IT.
>> Tucker: I COULD IMAGINE IF
I ASKED WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SEE WIN ON A DOESN’T MATTER
BECAUSE WE FEEL STRONG ABOUT OUR
CHANCES IN NOVEMBER.
IF NO ONE WAS AROUND AND I SAID
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE WIN, WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY?
>> BERNIE LOOKS VERY STRONG
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK WHENEVER YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT COMPARING ON
NOVEMBER 2020, 2 DIFFERENT
CANDIDATES, THEY COULDN’T BE
MORE DIFFERENT BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMP AND BERNIE SANDERS.
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT DOESN’T REALLY
MATTER TO US WHO IT IS BECAUSE
WE FEEL LIKE PEOPLE ARE FEELING
THE RESULT OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY AND VERY POSITIVE
WAYS EVERY DAY ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
WE FEEL GREAT AS WE GO INTO
NOVEMBER.
BUT LISTEN, IF YOU WANT TO START
CONTRASTING AND YOU WANT TO SHOW
PEOPLE HOW FRIGHTENING IT COULD
BE OUT THERE, I GUESS
BERNIE SANDERS COULD BE THAT
PERSON.
WE’LL HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE
PEOPLE OF IOWA AND ALL ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY DECIDE.
>> Tucker: IT KIND OF SEEMS
LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN HAS
FLATTENED -- THAT’S TOO STRONG.
WE’LL FIND OUT SOON.
SHE’S NOT PERFORMING IN THE WAY
THAT THE NATIONAL MEDIA EXPECTED
THREE MONTHS AGO.
DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU?
>> NO.
NOTHING SURPRISES ME.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY UNIQUE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD I THINK.
MY EXPERIENCES FROM 2016 WHEN I
WAS HERE IN IOWA CAUCUSING FOR
DONALD TRUMP, WHO DID NOT COME
IN FIRST PLACE.
AS WE KNOW THESE VERY EARLY
CAUCUSES AND PRIMARY ELECTIONS,
THINGS ARE ALWAYS DIFFERENT.
YOU CAN’T REALLY PREDICT THE
FUTURE BY THEM.
BUT IT’S BEEN A VERY INTERESTING
FIELD TO SEE AND I THINK FROM
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN PERSPECTIVE,
WE WOULD LOVE A CLEAR FRONT
RUNNER SO WE CAN FOCUSING ON
THAT PERSON.
IT REALLY HASN’T PANNED OUT THAT
WAY YET.
WE ARE ALL WATCHING, JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE COUNTRY,
AND TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Tucker: IT DOES SEEM
AWFULLY CHAOTIC.
FOR A PARTY THAT SAID FOR THREE
YEARS THAT ALL WE CARE ABOUT IS
BEATING TRUMP, THAT’S IT.
I DON’T CARE.
JUST GIVE ME SOME OF YOU CAN BE
TRUMP.
THERE IS NO CLEAR FRONT RUNNER.
DOES THAT SEEM STRANGE TO YOU?
>> IT SHOULD BE STRANGE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON ACTUALLY GETTING
ALONG WITH THIS PRESIDENT AND
DOING THINGS POSITIVE TO IMPACT
THIS COUNTRY, THEY HAVE BEEN
OBSESSED WITH TRYING TO GET HIM
OUT OF OFFICE.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE SPENT
THEIR TIME, I DON’T KNOW,
VETTING BETTER CANDIDATES AND
TRYING TO FIND PEOPLE THAT ARE
LIKABLE AS CANDIDATES.
INSTEAD THEY HAVE TRIED TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE PUT FORWARD THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX.
THEY WORKED AGAINST HIM THAT
EVERYTHING WILL TURN.
FORTUNATELY FOR THE COUNTRY, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL WITH EVERYTHING HE’S
DONE DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY
WORKED AGAINST HIM.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE PUT THEIR
ENERGY ELSEWHERE.
WHO KNOWS.
>> Tucker: I DON’T THINK THEY